Timur is a popular turkey seaside resort
and one weekend a year
it's the venue for the sea to sky
extreme enduro motorcycle race this year
marks the eighth edition of the
three-day event 180 riders from 23
countries are taking part the main race
starts on the beach before heading into
the forest and up olympus mountain to
the finish
might a real good day I managed to be in
front most of the day I'm just keeping a
good flood having fun there are 11
checkpoints along the 65 kilometer long
route steep cliffs and stony sections
make the course a real challenge see the
sky is regarded as one of the hardest
extreme enduro races with it's
constantly changing conditions the
three-day race pushes many riders to
their limits both physically and
mentally
my day was perfect from the beginning I
had a decent start
more like 4/5 then I ever passed the
riders yes after the super enduro and
after that I ride my own race I've been
living like one hour or something like
that it was really close following sea
to sky is so demanding then of the 180
writers who started the race just 47
reached the finish line the other's
bodies her bikes simply gave out
world-class riders like Mario Roman Wade
young Graham Jarvis and Johnny Walker
thrilled the crowds and gave it their
all to secure a place on the podium
Wade young has competed here several
times before this year he finished third
[Music]
happy to be on the podium I could have
been on any one of the three boxes today
we're all rode good together gram and
Mario we've pretty much wrote together
most of the day I was trying to save my
energy a [ __ ] for that last year and
grams just and animals so to try keep up
with him on there I also tied myself out
a bit more but you know what I'm on the
podium I've had a bit of bad luck the
last races so to finish and be on the
podium I'm stoked more deluxe being
first but I gave it everything today so
I'll take third I'm happy with that
Spaniard Mario Roman was the second
rider to reach the finish line
I'm really happy with the second place
Congrats to Bahamas Congrats to wait for
the for you none really happy with a
team effort
Sega factory team thanks everyone
English but Graham Jarvis took the
checkered flag the 42 year olds many
years of experience gave him the edge
I just can't believe a one because as
you know I was behind for so long and
then I was just thinking how this could
42 years old just give me my last chance
so I just had to keep going and pushing
as out of the car I'm gonna break the
front brake and have to fix it a little
bit but you know towards the end I don't
know what happened I just I just went
through and that little extra effort
paid off big in the end
[Music]